in Texas Mexicans have always been there
and the people who were there before we
had a country called Mexico so there's
very there's not this sense that
Mexicans are foreigners hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with Reason TV and today we
are talking with avec Roy he is the
president and co-founder of the
foundation for research on equal
opportunity thanks for talking to us
okay and you also call it free up free
up fr e OPP 1 e FR e OPP org what are
you trying to do with this new
organization well our mission is to
expand economic opportunity to those who
least have it using the tools of free
enterprise limited government and
technological innovation our idea is
that we you and I know Nick that free
markets have looked at more people out
of poverty than anything that has ever
been invented by man and yet a lot of us
in the free market community don't talk
about free markets in that way we don't
really try to explain to people who
aren't already with us how free markets
can make their lives better so our goal
is to create a think tank where every
scholar that we hire every op-ed that we
publish every white paper that we
generate will have to Center its
arguments around how a free market
oriented policy reform can make life
better for people with below median
income people with below median incomes
our net worth you recently spoke at an
event that your organization free up and
Reason sponsored about diversity and
kind of libertarian issues or diversity
and conservatives it was really a chance
to talk about how little traditionally
libertarians and conservatives have
really reached out to minorities
particularly blacks but also Latinos and
Asian's and others talk a little bit
about how that issue intersects with
what you're doing there and also your
location in Texas because you're big on
Texas as a model for not simply for
governance because Texas is kind of a
lohse it's it's a relatively low tax
state and a relatively low service state
that's doing very well in terms of
people want to move there but it's also
an incredibly diverse state and it seems
to have escaped many of the kind of
racial and ethnic clashes that we see in
other parts
the country let's start with the Texas
aspect of it so as you alluded to it to
the degree that there are conservatives
and libertarians out there who fear a
more diverse America because they worry
that say Mexicans or Asians don't come
from the anglo-american political
tradition I think Texas is a good
counter example to hopefully make them
think that that's not necessarily what
the outcome will be
Texas and majority minority state which
is one of the freest states in the
country by many of the indices that you
and I follow closely and and it's not
just a free country a free State in a
sense of just policy but but there
really is a sense that that everyone
feels whether white or Anglo or Latino
or neither of those categories that that
freedom has made their lives better
Hispanics in Texas vote routinely forty
five percent for the Republican Party to
the degree we associate Republicans with
a more free-market agenda and that's
that's seen in in the way that Anglos
and Latinos and others engage with each
other there just isn't that sense the
way other in other parts of America
there's a sense well these immigrants
are coming in and they're changing our
communities in ways we don't like in
Texas Mexicans have always been there
and the people who were there before we
we had a country called Mexico so
there's very there's not this sense that
Mexicans are foreigners there's very
much a sense that actually the Anglos
were the ones who came in and took Texas
over from the Mexicans and that this
community this this indigenous thing
that we call tex-mex has been around for
a very long time so that sense of not
simply not treating the others as if
they were the others that there were all
Texans together net unites Texans that
simple
attitude adjustment show is it's not an
adjustment for them but that attitude
makes a huge difference and people can
tell you know I think what we under
appreciate sometimes and people who are
in politics and intellectual circles how
much every American or every person has
an intuitive sense of whether you accept
them as a country fellow countryman or
whether you don't
and in Texas there's it's it's there's
people understand that there's that
genuine acceptance and I think a big
part of what we're trying to do it free
up is to help people appreciate that
that there's there have been basically
the approach that you see a lot of
Republicans take about minority outreach
is is to concede is to believe that the
only way to appeal to minorities is
through more statism to say that well
minorities like statism and so we have
to be more status in order to appeal to
them or else then you just write them
off or write them off you're right or
just give up because well we're not
status there forward it's not gonna
bother and our view is totally the
opposite that our view is that actually
there are a lot of people who are
non-white in America who actually are
entrepreneurial who value Liberty and
simply we just haven't been recognizing
that they're just as American as we are
that you know somebody who comes here
from India or Mexico but has bought his
pair of parents do but was born here is
just as American as someone whose
parents came here from Sweden or Germany
or England who was happens to be born
here talk a little bit about your your
political or ideological rqu we've
mentioned you've worked with Rick Perry
and you've worked with Mitt Romney in
the past you also worked as an advisor
for Marco Rubio are you a Republican are
you a conservative are you a libertarian
how do you define yourself and how did
you get that way growing up I wasn't
particularly politically conscious i I
didn't really and you grew up in
Michigan Michigan so if suburbs of
Detroit Oakland County where my dad
worked yeah I think I was instinctively
conservative but I didn't really know
what groans I didn't even know what
these terms meant but as time went on I
came to appreciate particularly when it
came to communism versus America I was
very much in the in the American side of
that event I would go back to India
sometimes I visit my relatives and and
my relatives are from a part of India
that was then run by at the state level
by the Communist Party West Bengal so
I'd go back there and argue with my
relatives when I was seven years old
about the invasion of Afghanistan by the
Soviet Union and how terrible that was
and they were on the wrong side of that
and so so that made me sort of I was
unconsciously perhaps conservator on the
right not really knowing what that meant
and I thought of myself perhaps is
somewhere I was like a libertarian and
then I became more conservative in the
sense that I came to appreciate culture
as mattering and and not merely
individual liberty that individual
Liberty matters it's perhaps a higher
key and argument that liberty and order
go together and can't be completely
separated from one
and I started to really read a lot of
political philosophy and I in my 20s and
became more conservative actually as a
result of that in the sense of the
Edmund Burke Aristotle David Hume
Richard Weaver kind of school of
conservatism believing the culture
mattered more and you believe I mean you
tend to be an incrementalist and you're
thinking you're not you're not looking
to pull everything up root and branch
but rather to modify stuff in a
direction that you find more effective
yeah so when I became when I left school
and actually got into the workforce that
was what started to move me in more of a
libertarian direction I think
particularly being in the investment
community where I was and seeing how the
business world work I came to really
appreciate the libertarian critique of
statism in a sense of understanding
economic incentives and understanding
how well-intentioned even conservative
well-intentioned policies that try to
regulate human behavior often will
result in perverse incentives and bad
outcomes and so based on that sense of
outcomes really mattering I became more
certainly more economically libertarian
and even on issues related to social
issues and culture I think where where
I'm sort of in-between libertarians and
conservatives is I don't dismiss again
the importance of culture the importance
of intact families for example the
importance of our cultural inheritance
in shaping how we look at the world and
how we engage with our communities I
think that's very important particularly
on issues of race right I think it's
very important understand that if you if
you're black and you're the descendant
of slaves that's gonna affect your
community and the way you interact with
America in a way that's just different
than if you're white and we can't just
assume that well just because you're
born today and in a post-civil rights
world it's all gone it's all erased so I
think that is something that
conservatives the Burkean type of
conservative understands that I still I
think I still believe in but I would
like to challenge that now yeah I mean
it seems to me that that's one of the
places where I think conservatives and
typical Republicans refused to to it to
believe that they are like no come on
look at all we've given you we fought
the civil war for you we've been do this
we did affirmative action and you're
still complaining that cops roust you at
more
and then then may as a white person yeah
I suspect there it's an interesting
switch that it's the libertarians who
are more thick in the culture and
realized that you can't just flip things
on it all I think I think you're
absolutely right and I I agree with what
you just said what I meant it more sort
of in a perhaps in a more philosophical
kind of abstract way that sure that the
that the that's strictly speaking a
philosophically consistent concern as
opposed to American political
conservatism philosophically consist a
Burkean conservative would understand
theoretically the importance of that
inheritance where the American political
conservatives let's close it out by
talking about Donald Trump is there a
fascinating character in the ways that
you're talking about because he and in
comical ways I mean when he you know he
says like I'm a self-made man I got a
small loan of a million dollars from my
father and look at me now I'm a big
success I started with nothing but it's
the rhetoric of you know self uplift and
pulling yourself up by bootstraps he's
also uses political connections whenever
he can he's you know he is the
Republican president he but he's not
really conservative is he go is he going
he's brash he uproots things is he going
to be good or bad do you think for
Entrepreneurship for the types of people
that you're trying to reach and free up
those people who are below the median
income because he actually more than
more certainly more than Mitt Romney but
you know the only thing Mitt Romney said
about the 47% was you know like forget
him they're not gonna vote for me anyway
he spoke to black crowds directly he
spoke to poor people he spoke to poor
whites what is your sense about Donald
Trump and and the project that you're
working on it free up I think I think we
have to start with any new president and
hope for the best
hope that we have the best outcome that
what you just described his aspirations
of helping lower-income Americans who
are struggling in this economy that it
succeeds that whether it's the free
market stuff or the the non free-market
stuff that you and I might bite might
look at scan set whatever at the end of
the halls ends up being let's hope that
it succeeds and that people rise up from
it it's
only my view that that the policies at a
more market-oriented that are directed
towards improving job growth in areas
where there hasn't been any are going to
be very important and and I think that
what Donald Trump has shown us is that
and this is what we were talking about
at the forum that you mentioned earlier
how important dignity is in politics I
think so often people like us we get
caught up in ideology in philosophy in
economic policy we forget how much
people are willing to vote for someone
who they might even disagree with on
economics but who they believe actually
really cares about people like them and
recognizes the dignity of the way
they're trying to live their lives and
their aspirations and Donald Trump did
that for a lot of people who don't
trician a traditionally vote Republican
who are white and we've just got to hope
that over time free marketeers are able
to do that same service for people who
are not white alright well we will leave
it there we have been talking with ovah
crow he's the founder a co-founder and
president of the foundation for research
on equal opportunity also called free op
FR e OPP org avec thanks so much for
talking to us Nick it's an honor
[Music]